yo what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and we got one of the best
most epic chapters of one piece to talk
about today
this truly is hype af a legendary
chapter so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these one piece
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is channel the
pirate king within and smash
that like button until it's blue i've
been doing these chat reviews for over a
year now and it's crazy how fast that
flew by
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop which will be in two
weeks feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist which includes videos
about the yonko warlord supernova and
much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all
right off the bat you know a chapter is
going to be epic when the title is
conquerors hockey we start with big mom
falling off the island and down towards
the
ocean she's worried and begging to be
saved by zeus but zeus is still trapped
prometheus is getting cut by zorro
while law is amazed that her boy zorro
is still going after the last attack
probably broke
every bone in his body classic zorro
zorro just
keeps stepping up and it says a lot
about luffy's crew that zorro has been
more impressive in this battle than the
other two supernova captains so far
luffy and zoro have consistently been
distinguishing themselves
and i've been pointing it out along the
way but here luffy will separate himself
from the other captains even more
clearly
but more on that later before that kaido
is remarking how pathetic big mom
is and how he has to save her it's very
cool that supernova
made a yonko need saving luffy looks
passed out for now
but like i said last chapter i don't
think these injuries will be that
serious
but for the moment he lays there as
kaido goes to attack
zorro and free prometheus so the homie
can go and help big mom
lost switch places with zorro and hits
kaido with an injection
shot making him cough up blood law also
gets the compliment from kaido when he
says that law's abilities really throw
him off
and i enjoy how much the strongest
creature in the world is complimenting
our guys throughout this fight i still
find it crazy that we've gotten to the
point where characters are seriously
giving to yonko
trouble in a prolonged fight zoro being
the legend he is even tells law he
shouldn't have saved him because now the
flame thing
is going to save big mom the dude would
gladly have risked death to accomplish
the goal but law is not down with anyone
of the supernova dying which you gotta
appreciate the bromance is strong with
these two
and even kid is cool with the decision
saying that they just needed to split
them up
and kid and killer go take on big mom
i'm excited to see what these two might
accomplish against her moving forward we
then get big mom praising prometheus and
cursing zeus
prometheus asks for a favor and kit and
killer notice something strange about
the clouds let me know what you guys are
expecting here
what's prometheus got in mind we jump
back to unconscious luffy who
is again glaring at kaido kaido is
contemplating the ways he'll kill luffy
when zorro once again steps up for his
captain
he tells law he's reached his limit and
he can only launch one more attack he
says if it doesn't work and he ends up
dead it's up to lob
man zoro is just so badass
chapter after chapter willing to lay it
all on the line at any point i really
respect the dude he tells kaido that
luffy is his captain
and the yonko should take his head
before he gets ahead of himself
i'm so glad zoro was part of the yonko
fight here i cannot describe
how glad in words oda really delivered
with the epic zorro moments during this
battle
zorro uses post time skip 9 sword style
asura farce of the dead
it's epic it's hype but it doesn't bring
kaido down
nevertheless kaido is shocked suggesting
that zorro
has conquers hockey too which people
have been hoping for
for so long zoro doesn't know what he
means but we know how epic this
is and if he does in fact have it he
joins such a top
tier epic group of individuals since
rayleigh and katakuri have it
i think it's very fitting for zoro to
have it as well even if he didn't knock
kaido down as he hoped
this builds the hype for how strong zoro
will continue to get in the future kairu
even compliments zaro saying that his
attack will leave a scar
and that should be enough for the
supernova and honestly leaving a scar on
the strongest creature in the world is a
pretty huge accomplishment that should
not be slept on
another person we know that did that was
odin and odin was epic af
kaido has to admit this generation is
such a pain
and those kinds of statements are always
music to my ears kaido hits zorro and
law with a lightning fast
thunder bhagwa kaido still considers it
a pity they didn't
join him since they could have taken
over the world together
and i get how he feels as a captain he's
always looking for talent
and these guys have it in boatloads
however luffy gets up and
unlike last time he's not even close to
being out of commission after losing
consciousness
he says no one would team up with an
idiot like kaido he promises to
send the strongest creature in the world
flying
this dude's got some serious serious
king energy already luffy recalls yogurt
teaching him about coating himself in
haki
and letting it flow from his fist he
also told him that in the middle of
danger
that power truly blooms and i love the
flower imagery there
and i love that idea that when pushed
into a corner
you can pull out more resources than you
ever thought you had
and see what you're truly capable of
luffy is about to surpass his limits
luffy points out that kaido uses
conquerors haki
to code himself and kaido says only a
handful of powerful individuals can do
it
and then this chapter that's already
been crazy good
gets even better just when kaido is sure
he'll finish off luffy
luffy uses conker's hockey himself and
we see what we
saw when whitebeard and the pirate king
clashed
not only the black streaks but also
these two are clashing without making
direct contact
law is amazed and luffy is doing
amazingly well
clearly having the upper hand right now
punching kaido around
obviously it won't be that easy and
kaido might have been caught off guard
but it's definitely not a coincidence
that oda is drawing parallels between
luffy versus kaido
and whitebeard vs roger luffy appears to
be on a whole
other level compared to the other
supernova right now and accordingly
he tells them to leave the rest to him
he wants them to head back down as he
confidently says
he's got this he's confident that
one-on-one
he can beat kaido and that's so hyped
since we got that quote before that in a
one-on-one fight
always bet on kaido and yet luffy's
mastery of conquerors haki
may actually let him back up his claim
as he continues to use it in creative
ways
it's so funny because kid wanted to take
down kaido but he went after big mom
without a second thought
and now luffy is gonna go against kaido
by himself
the story is making it blatantly clear
in these ways that luffy is the one
he's the leader he's the future pirate
king i gotta admit i keep hoping that
zorro has an ace up his sleeve
and he'll open his closed eye and
everyone will just go crazy but
it's suggested that he did everything he
could do here and you honestly
can't be dissatisfied with zorro in this
battle he was legendary
however luffy is clearly number one and
as zoro says he's given it his all
luffy appears to be just getting started
and that is it for this
one let me know what you thought of it
and what you look forward to seeing
next i could not be happier with this
chapter and where the story is right now
i almost feel like luffy is getting too
strong too quick
and i'm actually worried about the story
wrapping up sooner rather than later
if he beats the strongest creature in
the world but when you compare one piece
to the power growth in almost any other
shonen oda's definitely spent much more
time allowing his protagonist to get
stronger and the fact that i'm actually
worried about a series that's over 1 000
chapters long ending
shows just how amazing oda is at long
term storytelling
after 1010 chapters i can honestly say
this is about as excited as i've ever
been
to see what happens next anyways if you
did enjoy this review
and if you enjoyed zorro and luffy's
legendary displays
make sure to channel the pyroking within
and smash that like button
until it's blue as kaido if nothing else
smash the like button to celebrate over
a year
of these one-piece chapter reviews if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop
which will be in two weeks feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
which includes videos on the yonko
warlords supernova and much more link to
that
is in the description and i especially
want to thank the patron squad on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord twego himself alpha
sigma red-haired raven
and javier rojas and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stay on top
all clans ingrata pate heffa al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi bang
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis and yuno
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski cricket xp
return day aura very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks here coming in water
joanne garcia 10 note 10 iceparky65
jessica lafon fatboy games deadly saint
and soul rye
slice and dice thank you all so much if
you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patronly discord where we talk
about the latest
chapters anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
animeoutpro
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already smashed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space
cowboys
[Music]
you